[Music]
who needs Matthew McConaughey when you
got his older brother self-made
millionaire rooster I'm hanging out with
him in Midland Texas
and clearly we're not in Hollywood
anymore great to meet you hello Danny
rooster et we're here where you put oh
we're starting early hot you know what
When in Rome right see I hear you guys
have a steer around yeah come on let's
go Jacky Mouse do it
[Music]
please look Danny
see that water paraty that's what had
the last calorie buddy that is an animal
pretty much food you want Sancho good
boy
there you go oh we don't see these in LA
I'll tell you that right now
you got at least stepping [ __ ] if you're
gonna text I mean I've been here 10
minutes this is just one of roosters
ranches in Midland a place he's called
home for 40 years and as I found out
touring this 50 acre property he never
wants to leave
all right butcher sober enough right
yeah have you ever thought about ever
leaving Texas whatever I know it's never
really crawled from mine a gopher
I can see why not you know what I mean
you think about maybe have a second home
somewhere but I don't think I'd always
have to have roots here no do I get the
worst I am about it you know you guys
are big old reality stars ever think of
setting up shop in LA no no no rooster
and Butch and close friend Gil returned
for the second season of their CNBC show
West Texas investors Club et got a
special invite behind the scenes what
does it take to win you guys over you
know what are you looking for in a
potential investment we're looking for
someone that reminds us a lot really we
are when they leave when they leave here
other than the most important thing
to help them help them fail we admire
the fact that your entrepreneurial
you're trying to do the things that your
dad has done and you know I can relate
to that I worked for my dad I always
wanted to be able to you know better the
business and take over the business and
accelerate and so talk to me about you
know your first million how did you make
your money you first started out you
were thirty amazing that that I that I
lost in about two days or something that
that's the story I made it yeah when I
went in up I'd always see it up when I
moved amid and I was like 21 22 years
old I said you know I think I probably
I'm gonna try to make a million dollars
for him 30 years old and I did but it
didn't last very long
I mean I mean I rang the bell and I was
kicked out of the park
roosters come a long way since then his
net worth is estimated to be worth over
55 million dollars giving his famous kid
brother a run for his money
16 years older than did the math you
always say I said I was I was a famous
drunk before he put crapping his pants
you know the math you started getting
famous that was you know it was a lot of
fun I remember that we went out there
after the daisies between premieres and
we stayed up all night but Lema o'clock
that morning I get a call from the house
house and producing cents and it's with
anglers in the outfield and I said
what's the deal man we can't find
Matthew you can't find Matthew said I
said I said what he said when we think
he missed his plane I said well you need
that far here laughs I'm the back out of
Eagle make it on time to birthday on
fire that son of a [ __ ]
luckily for Matthew he made it and so
did et yes American dream in there it's
pretty tough to be